now
we're gonna make an amazing butter
and this
is sort of the start of the the most
important part keeping that bird
incredibly moist soft butter
a touch of salt and pepper
little touch of olive oil in there
that stops the butter from burning
next add the zest of two lemons
and their juice this gives the flavored
butter a wonderful citrus zing
three cloves of garlic
turkeys are very delicate dainty meat
and that's why i want the garlic pureed
so it sort of disintegrates
and flavors a turkey
gently without becoming too overpowering
then add a generous handful of chopped
parsley
wow that smells incredibly light give
that a good mix
turkey's a very very very lean bird and
it dries out
so it's so important
to make sure that we help it to cook
perfectly
butter done now prepare the turkey we'll
season the bird
inside the cavity
salt and pepper
next half two onions and pop them in
as they roast they steam inside the bird
giving a lovely sweetness
put in the lemon and a couple of bay
leaves for their bittersweet spicy
flavour
[Music]
we're sort of
lining the inside of the turkey with
these fantastic
sort of flavours you can see the bird is
upright and it's looking sort of like
it's standing to attention now it's time
to add the flavored butter just very
very carefully
open up the skin
go through
over the back of the breast
and keep the skin intact
the idea is to gently loosen the skin
with your fingers so the butter can be
stuffed underneath it
now once you've loosened all the skin
off the top of the thighs turn the bird
around
and just go through here again hand up
and just release
a little bit but don't completely break
it because i don't want all that butter
to run out
right
from there
now take your butter
put it into a ball
that smells amazing
lemony
citrusy and just
sort of flatten it
and stick that in there
underneath
one side now once you've got it in there
pull back the skin
and just
use that
to sort of slide all the way down
what we want to do now is line the top
of the breast with all that butter there
that butter is going to keep the turkey
breast really seriously moist
turn the bird round
and finish covering the breasts with the
butter
turkeys originally came from north
america and they are best young and
plump my favorite breed for christmas is
either north of black or norfolk bronze
both of which have a wonderful gamey
taste
take the rest of the butter and
carefully massage over the breast legs
and wings
you can do all this the night before and
simply cover the turkey with tinfoil and
keep it in the fridge ready to be cooked
on christmas day
into the tray
a little touch
of olive oil now olive oil on top again
that protects it gets that skin really
nice and crispy and it stops the butter
from burning
now in the oven at 220 for 10 minutes to
get really nice and brown
quickly
in she goes
beautiful
[Music]
that smells fantastic
after 10 minutes take the turkey out of
the oven and baste then cover the
breasts with smoked streaky bacon
what i want to do
is add a little bit more flavor i'm
already starting to think
about my gravy
so the bacon protects it stops it from
drying out
but it's going to start
to really give
my gravy a wonderful base
turn down the oven to 180 degrees
this five kilogram bird will feed eight
people comfortably it needs roasting for
two and a half hours or half an hour per
kilo basting every so often
[Music]
back in
and now
she's on the way look at that beautiful
that smells
fantastic
wow
look at that
beautiful
that
is 90 of your work done there
to test the turkey is cooked stick a
knife into the bottom of the thigh and
if the juices run clear it's done the
secret now is to let the turkey rest
uncovered for two and a half hours as
the meat relaxes it reabsorbs its juices
making it succulent and tender plus
it'll be easier to carve
it might seem like a long time to let it
rest but remember the turkey doesn't
need to be piping hot because i'm
serving it with hot gravy
that
looks like a million dollars
let that rest
because the flavor will be 10 times more
exciting once it's rested as that
turkey's resting
i want to make the most amazing gravy
when i say amazing i really do mean
amazing
drain the excess fat from the roasting
tray and put it back on the heat
then remove the bacon from the top of
the turkey
and the roasted onions from the cavity
look at them
my god they smell amazing
finally take out the roasted lemon
first of all cut up the bacon
lovely
bacon into the tray
hear how crispy that is
that's the start
of our gravy
the onion look at it
beautiful
it doesn't get any better than that chop
that up
onion
and bacon in
that
smells
incredible
when i first got the chance to cook
christmas lunch for the chefs in paris
they taught me one crucial thing
i was only 21 at the time
and they made me rest the turkey for as
long as i cooked it
so i cooked it for three hours and i
rested it for three hours
what a difference
incredible
next chop up the roasted lemon and add
to the tray
put in a couple of sprigs of rosemary to
give it a lovely aromatic punch and fry
then add three chopped tomatoes which
helps thicken the gravy and give it a
lovely fresh taste
[Music]
now it's time to really get the turkey
flavor into the gravy snap off
the wing
take off all your little trimmings all
these little bits here
add that into your crayfi
these are the bits we never use
everyone throws them away
off
there that little baby there
take him off
i want that
bang flavor delicious try that off
it smells incredible
next pour in the dry cider this adds a
lovely subtle apple flavor that really
lifts the taste of the turkey meat
as the cider starts to reduce pour in
the delicious resting juices from the
roasted turkey
wow there you go
the most amazing flavor
[Music]
when the liquid has reduced by half
crush the vegetables and the turkey
pieces with a masher to extract the
maximum amount of flavor
and basically what's happening now is
that we're giving the gravy a little bit
of body
pour in the chicken stock and reduce
again
in
now a little taste
wow i mean just close your eyes wow it
oozes flavor and turkey now sieve it
use the back of the ladle to push it
through the sieve extracting every last
drop of flavor
pop in a sprig of rosemary and leave to
infuse ready for the finishing touch
[Music]
simply add crushed walnuts to the bottom
of the gravy boat and ladle in the hot
gravy we're just going to do again a
little twist the potatoes we do need
some goose fat
no no
goose fat so we're going to do a really
nice
lightly spiced
roast potato okay little chili flake
really yeah chili flake just put a
little bit of heat in there for the
christmas lunch yup chili flake and a
little bit of turmeric
i can't believe you're doing roast
potatoes with chili
now would you be so kind just to give
them a little cut cut the peeled
potatoes into quarters and put into
salted cold water
in they go
okay bring them up to the boil and
simmer for around eight minutes
drain and let them steam
then season with salt and pepper on
there and just a little teaspoon
of chili flake
no that's the sort of thing i would make
for supper and a saturday night or
something you know really
chilly flakes in add a teaspoon of
turmeric
turmeric is a member of the ginger
family it stains the potatoes a
wonderful golden color and has a lovely
earthy taste
next drizzle in a little olive oil and
shake to coat them just let them roll
around
yeah that smells nice beautiful could
you get me the
stuffing please from the fridge
put in a preheated baking tray with
extra olive oil and cook at 200 degrees
celsius for about 40 minutes give a
little shake to make sure they don't
stick
and then i'll just stick the stuffing
up
on top here
now that will take roughly about the
same time as potatoes stuffing in
potatoes done
nice why are you gonna play with the
kids i will do here okay see you shortly
thank you bye-bye
now they
look
and smell fantastic
look at that
beautiful chicken with garlic and
chestnut stuffing packed with flavor and
earthy richness
for the stuffing fry finely chopped
onion garlic
and celery in hot olive oil
next add pine nuts which have a lovely
creamy taste and chopped earthy cooked
chestnuts
both add a wonderfully chewy texture and
richness to stuffings
season
and add chopped parsley
[Music]
then stir in cooked wild rice
[Music]
next take a whole deboned chicken it's
fitting to do at home but if you ask
your butcher will do it for you and pile
the stuffing mixture along the center
now simply roll the chicken up tightly
and tie it with your butcher string
[Music]
then roast in a hot oven for just over
an hour
[Music]
simply carve into magnificent thick
slices
so impressive so easy and trust me this
is a dish guaranteed to get a fantastic
reaction on any occasion
turkey the one hit wonder i'm absolutely
amazing bird
stuff
onion
orange garlic thyme and bailey
season
truffle butter
this little beauty helps to take the
turkey to a different division these
cost 50 quid for that size yes it's
expensive but boy is it worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
don't chop the truffle too small because
we want to taste and identify the
truffle
parsley
tarragon
salt touch of pepper
tablespoon of olive oil and that stops
the butter from burning
take your piping bag
and fill it
separate skin from meat
[Music]
bag in
butter
massage
salt
pepper
olive oil
roast
citrus breadcrumbs
[Music]
pancetta
[Applause]
onion
[Applause]
thyme
good old chef trick and pull down
and just peel it off his lovely flowers
pine nuts
butter
[Music]
[Applause]
bread
orange
lemon
[Music]
[Applause]
and to start browning sprinkle your
orange and lemon breadcrumbs
lemon juice
[Applause]
there we go
beautiful
rest
tin foil keeps it nice and warm and it
cools down slowly so the breasts become
really nice and moist
calm
what you can smell of course is that
amazing truffle
absolutely beautiful
turkey with truffle butter and citrus
breadcrumbs done